look at these trailers they don't stop
now they got a trailer for the amazing -
a spider-man this code and there's a
Super Bowl TV spot for the amazing
spider-man - but luckily we actually
have a three and a half minute trailer
for the amazing spider-man - so I
figured let's just talk about that one
it makes a little more sense at the
beginning you see Jamie Foxx he's just
really nerdy dorky dude he's just hero
worship spider-man he runs into
spider-man spider-man has some words
with him he's like holy [ __ ] you're you
Ben later on he's just talking about
like how man spider-man he's the best
right and then you go to his mancave and
it's the creepiest [ __ ] you've ever seen
yes photos of spider-man everywhere
among his photos he has a little mirror
where his face can be among spider-man
we're loving this is sy the photo guy
from one hour photo creepy he's one of
those dudes gotta be careful with you
look out of you're like you're not
saying and then just saying you're a
time bomb it's what you are man he gets
electrocuted and falls into a vat of
electric eels he starts getting fried
the whole tank blows up you're like well
he's dead but this is a comic book movie
you don't die from that [ __ ] under the
right circumstances people are nuke
proof in comic book movies he emerges as
electro his skins blue and he sees
spider-man again I really like this
scene because he's almost unrecognizable
and he looks a spider mean it's like you
don't remember me do you spider-man's
like sure you are you're my eyes and
ears out there which is what he told him
when he first met him you get the
feeling that he just says all you're my
eyes and ears out there to everybody
when you're talking to a dude who is
straight-up stalker vibe and you forget
his name and he realizes that you just
say that to everybody it's probably
gonna shoot you in the chest with his
newfound lightning bolt powers I'm just
saying logic dictates that's gonna
happen and that's what happens which is
funny I do have to think about this [ __ ]
bear with me on this Jamie Foxx a former
in living color cast member plays a
character in a comic book movie who
hero-worship someone that someone lets
them down then to become a supervillain
they're coming after that guy Jim Carrey
in Batman Forever
a former in living color cast member
plays a character in a comic book movie
who hero worship someone that someone
lets them down then to become a
supervillain he's coming after that guy
amazing spider-man 2 looks like it's
gonna be a lot better than Batman
Forever I'm saying that cracked me up
and made me laugh I really like the song
that comes on the trailer after Jamie
Foxx falls into the eels and doesn't die
it is just I'm walking like he's like a
leper or something he's an electric
zombie it's a really cool song it got me
kind of jacked up the insanity ensues
are all coming after spider-man
spider-man has to take on electro Green
Goblin Rhino although this trailer did
call my mind a bit
you feel like rhinos gonna be at the
very beginning when he meets Jamie Foxx
he's in a rush obviously so you feel
like he's going after the Rye now I
don't know that I'm just kind of
speculating on the off-chance I'm right
he goes after the Rhino locks him up
rhinos just in this movie at the very
beginning to set up for the sinister six
movie the movie primarily focuses on
Jamie Foxx electro and the Green Goblin
aspect which makes the movies seem a lot
less crowded since we're now dealing
with two villains really well I know who
the creep is who's like we've had plans
for you spider-man the guy at the end of
the amazing spider-man 1 the guy in the
trailer to this one who is he I know who
the actor is he's that guy it looks like
creepy Van Damme if you know don't tell
me I don't actually want to know I'm
throwing that out there I'm thinking out
loud don't spoil the movie even if I
asked for it don't do that his trailer
Peter Parker's feeling really good he's
like you know what I love about being
spider-man everything he's got a new
suit and [ __ ] everyone's chanting Spidey
Spidey
it's like Arsenio Hall they're all like
whoo-hoo-hoo I hope they touch on the
premise that is that old phrase is that
we build our heroes up so we can tear
them down I want to see spider-man feel
that good so we can just drop and lose
everything everyone's like screw that
[ __ ] I don't know what I would when
he's trying to take out an electric man
that clearly blows up Times Square I'm
just saying do you see that in a trailer
they blow up Times Square I was like is
that a nightmare Peter Parker's having
or did they actually just suffer 9/11
part two I don't know that's what
writers are for it's why we speculate
the amazing spider-man 2 I'm actually
really jacked for if they play their
cards right it could be a good setup for
a sinister six movie and not be
overcrowded like spider-man 3 so the
amazing spider-man 2 have you seen the
trailer what did you think about it
whatever he's not comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more it's
not the same
you
[Music]